the first day of school when in the
usa
i can't speak english because i didn't
know how to say hello
so i decided to draw i thought good
man everyone understands a little
drawing of a marrazzo lower whatever it
was because i didn't draw it so i can
communicate for the rest of my  classmates
and my teachers
[Music] when
I was little I never imagined that my
drawings or my images john would have a
global effect but I always knew they
would help me
[Music]
my name is Ángel Agustín and I am a
designer and entrepreneur who knows that
the  tav and I'm starting my company that
seriously lost boy was very
small that I wasn't studying
architecture
that I already sat next to him and also
if nobody would make his models and draw
let's say things in perspective
and easy that I started in my action
[Music]
in the  2009 when I was about to
record was when he entered the giant social network
in the usa I was the only one in
my class who had a job with a
large company that was located  ca in rabbit and
if we go for phones that have been brought
to market
when I already knew all the equipment you have
to draw a lot of small icons
like 480 what you have to do but
luckily I could get a raise because they have taught me a
lot about it and between  he and
I finished them in three months
at the time the symbols were going to
come out I never imagined the impact they were
going to have globally
[Music]
my company is called team chico
our name is based on one of the
oldest trees on the planet
like the tree has very, very
old roots the concept from which the
idea of typical was born is from my own Colom
ian roots and Latin roots [Musi
] my pl
n from day one has been to focus
a lot on connecting with mysel
itself not in the world we live
in now in my opinion it is very important to have
that option
if those roots are not lost
[Music]
ah